de ces sacs plastiques cette archéologue
aguerris extraites un trésor qu'il
dévoile au public l'impression plombs
dans le corps de buffy si tous ces
fragments de squelettes il y en a des
arguments de milliers de dizaines de
milliers de ce fragment qu'on a trouvé
autant d'objets qu'il a patiemment
prélever du sol un an durant à
pontarlier avec l'équipe qu'il dirige
des bijoux de la poterie des silex de la
préhistoire et du moyen-âge ça me fait
du taf et le travail parce que on a
vraiment énormément de matériel trouvé
sur le terrain est donc là il faut le
tout traité tout analysé donc par le
spécialiste spéciste faune spécialistes
ce remix pugiliste monnaie etc pour en
tirer le maximum d'informations bien que
parcellaires les informations sont
transmises au public qui n'en rate pas
une miette
on apprend ainsi que pontarlier
accueillait un village mérovingiens au
vième et viième siècle
et puis sur le terrain on s'interroge
l'occupation humaine dans le secteur
remontent tel à bien plus loin à la
préhistoire
la géologie étudier dans cette tranche
et le dira peut-être un jour
c'est à la fois pour la recherche
scientifique parce que ça remet en
choses en question pas mal de choses sur
le sur les modèles qu'on connaît d'eux
d'évolution géologique du massif du jura
pour la géologie récente et puis après
de toute manière ça a toujours vocation
à être diffusée auprès du public
en attendant le travail de fouille des
archéologues touche à sa fin il faut
terminer avant le 16 octobre
mais l on l'a vu l'essentiel a déjà été
ramassés